Hey, gang, Jason Bateman here, doing a cold open for SmartLess. I'm all by myself. I don't have the other two guys. So this is the horrifying look into what this podcast would be without Sean Hayes and Will Arnett. Just me. Talking. Gaps. No fun.
大家好，我是杰森·贝特曼，为《SmartLess》做个开场白。就我一个人。另外两个家伙都不在。所以，这是个可怕的窥视，让你看看如果没有肖恩·海耶斯和威尔·阿奈特，这个播客会变成什么样。只有我。说话。冷场。没意思。
No humor. Nothing interesting. Welcome to SmartLess. All right. So, Listener, we've got Will Beaming in from Bozman, Montana. We've got Sean P. Hayes there in downtown Hollywood. he thought oh there it is scottie is applying chapstick onto sean's lips because that's the role they like to play wow that just happened yeah well jason threatened that he don't do it and i may him do it that was uh does scottie ever call from the restroom i'm done sean
没有幽默感。索然无味。欢迎收听 SmartLess。行吧。那么，听众朋友们，威尔从蒙大拿州博兹曼远程连线。肖恩·P·海耶斯在好莱坞市中心。他想，哦，来了，斯科蒂正在给肖恩涂润唇膏，因为这就是他们喜欢扮演的角色，哇，刚才还真发生了，是啊，呃，因为杰森威胁说如果不涂，他就得自己涂，那是，呃，斯科蒂会从洗手间打电话来吗？我好了，肖恩。
wipey oh okay no no no no not in a while not in a while not Willie, don't, Will, don't you miss the days. Don't you miss the days of wiping the bums and changing the diaper and the whole, like, shushing them to bed? And then what about doing that to your kids? Oh, Sean, you. Sean, you, son of a gun. I do miss it. I just, we just sort of, especially now, my little guy is five.
擦干净了，哦，好吧，不，不，不，不，最近没有，最近没有。威尔，别这样，威尔，难道你不怀念那些日子吗。难道你不怀念那些擦屁股、换尿布、还有哄他们睡觉的日子吗？那对你自己的孩子做这些呢？哦，肖恩，你呀。肖恩，你这个机灵鬼。我是挺怀念的。我只是，我们只是，特别是现在，我小家伙五岁了。
Yeah. He just seems like such a big boy now. Yeah, but he just seems like such a big boy now. When is he six? What is his birthday? In May. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
对。他现在看起来像个大男孩了。对，但他现在看起来真像个大男孩了。他什么时候六岁？他生日是什么时候？五月。哦，是吗。是啊。
How about that? Yeah. Now, Sean, you know, we can cut this. And this is getting too personal. Oh, we can cut this in. We can get this into the middle of another episode, drop it in. Have you and Scotty ever had a serious conversation about maybe adopting? You know, it's funny you said it.
怎么样？对。现在，肖恩，你知道的，我们可以剪掉这段。这变得太私人了。哦，我们可以把这段剪掉。我们可以把它剪辑到另一集的中间，插进去。你和斯科蒂有没有认真讨论过领养的事？你知道你这么说很有意思。
Yes, but no, like I, it's unfortunate that now, right now, at this age is the time I'm like, oh boy, I could really have a kid. I think it would be really fun to be a dad. But unfortunately, it feels like it's too late because of the energy that it requires and all that. Energy, yes. And so I feel like my brain. That's what a staff is for, Sean. I can see you're so staffed up, right?
是的，不过也不是，就是，遗憾的是现在，就在现在，在这个年龄，我才觉得，天哪，我真的很想有个孩子。我觉得当爸爸一定会很有趣。但不幸的是，感觉现在已经太晚了，因为照顾孩子需要耗费太多的精力，诸如此类的。精力，对。所以我觉得我的脑子。这就是助理存在的意义，肖恩。我看得出你请了好多助理，对吧？
Couldn't you will? Like three night nurses, four nannies. Yeah, but then I would feel bad about the kid because the kid wouldn't, like, I'd have to take it to Disneyland. I'd be too tired. Yeah, but you'd be like, you know, like the old millionaire, distant unavailable dad in the wheelchair. Barkin orders
威尔，你难道不会吗？比如三个夜班护士，四个保姆。对，但那样我对孩子就会感到很内疚，因为孩子不会，比如说，我都得带它去迪士尼乐园。我会太累的。是啊，但你可以扮演那种，你知道的，就像老派的百万富翁，坐在轮椅上冷漠又疏离的父亲。发号施令。
Yeah From the No but I mean You don't mean Like my brain is there But like I It's My brain came too late
对。从那不，但我的意思是，你不是那个意思。就像我的脑子到了那个状态，但就像我，我的脑子开窍得太晚了。
I think you'd be great No matter what Me too Me too I know what would happen Is it would happen And you would be Absolutely obsessed
我觉得你一定能当个好爸爸，不管怎样。我也是。我也是。我知道会发生什么，那就是事情真的发生了，而你绝对会。
Sean in the best way Yeah And 50's the new 30 Oh no What are you gonna do Your headphones are plugged in You took your sweater up I know
肖恩，绝对是全心全意地。对，而且五十岁就是全新的三十岁。哦，不。你这是在干什么？你的耳机线插着呢。你把毛衣套上去了。我懂的。
I can't unplug the fucking I took my sweater off over my headphones and I'm stuck. This is the guy who tries to take his sweater off in the car when he's driving. You know what, J.B., I think it's better he didn't have a kid. You know what I mean? I just saw that.
我拔不掉这该死的，我把毛衣套在耳机外面了，然后卡住了。这就是那个在开车时试图在车里脱毛衣的家伙。你知道吗，J.B.，我觉得他没生孩子其实更好。你知道我的意思吗？我刚刚看到那一幕了。
I need the parents. You imagine him trying to collapse a stroller? Oh, my God. By the way, trying to get it in the trunk. It would collapse me. Nothing tests your intellect more than trying to figure out how to collapse one of those strollers. Or by putting in a car seat
我需要那些父母。你能想象他试图折叠婴儿车吗？天哪。顺便说一句，试图把它塞进后备箱。这能把我折腾崩溃。没有什么比试图弄懂怎么折叠那些婴儿车更能考验你的智商了。或者把它放进汽车安全座椅里。
and trying to strap in the, the seatbelt thing behind it and the anchors. I'm still in the booster phase. I'm out of the full car seat, but I am still in the booster phase, and it is, I still do have sweaty moments. I'm trying to find the thing, the hook underneath.
然后试图扣上后面的安全带装置和固定扣。我还处在增高垫阶段。我已经不用全尺寸安全座椅了，但我还在用增高垫阶段，这真的很折磨人，我还是会急出一身汗。我试图找到那个东西，底下的挂钩。
And I'm like, just one second, one second. And then I'm, oh, God. You just push. But a lot of parents are really bad marketers at it because the second the baby goes crazy and it's having a tantrum that's in its arms, they look over their shoulder and they mouth to you, they go,
然后我会说，等一下，就一秒钟。然后我就，天哪。你只要推一下就行。但很多父母在推销育儿经方面真的很烂，因为一旦婴儿发疯开始大哭大闹，他们就会越过肩膀对你做个口型，他们会说，
don't have a kid. I know. Do you know what I mean? And you're just like, well, now I don't want to because I just so witnessed that. Yeah, but those are just the moments, you know? What was the line, Sean, that used to always use? You'd say, like, I'd have kids.
别生孩子。我知道。你知道我的意思吗？然后你就会觉得，好吧，我现在不想生了，因为我刚刚亲眼目睹了这一幕。是啊，但那只是一些时刻，你知道吗？肖恩，你以前常说的那句台词是什么？你会说，比如，我要生孩子。
I'd rather regret not having them than have them and regret it later. Yeah, it's a great line. Isn't it? Isn't it? I mean, it's just, it's abstract, but it's great. Warming. Yeah.
我宁愿后悔没生，也不愿生了之后再后悔。对，这是一句很棒的台词。不是吗？不是吗？我是说，这有点抽象，但真的很棒。温暖。对。
I don't know. Boy, listen, you got Ricky, you know? Yeah, by the way. He just barks every once in a while. I saw J.B. Sean, I haven't seen you in forever. I know. I haven't seen you in forever.
我不知道。天哪，听着，你还有里奇，对吧？对，顺便说一句。他只是偶尔叫几声。我看到J.B.了。肖恩，我都好久没见你了。我知道。我都好久没见你了。
Yeah, so sweet Willie last night. Oh, where? Some fancy, fancy thing in a bar. Oh, the governor's thing. That's it. I didn't know that was last night. I was last night. And I said to, I actually said in my thing,
哦，威尔昨晚太甜了。哦，在哪？酒吧里某个非常fancy的活动。哦，州长的活动。就是那个。我不知道那是昨晚。我昨晚在那。而且我对，我甚至在我的发言中说。
I said a few words at the start, and I said, I mentioned the podcast, and I said, and Jason's actually here today. And if you see him, just go up and touch him. Hug him. He loves strangers. It's like a receiving line. Wait, so did you know I was going to be there?
我在开头说了几句话，我提到了这个播客，我说，杰森其实今天也在这里。如果你看到他，就走过去摸摸他。拥抱他。他喜欢陌生人。就像一个接待队列。等等，所以你知道我要去吗？
Or did you improvise that? I just improvised that. Yeah, just in the moment. This guy's got skills. He's not afraid of a microphone in the spotlight. It was a crazy room, and I wanted to make sure to be just kind of respectful, and it was such a great night. How was it?
还是你即兴发挥的？我只是即兴发挥的。对，就那一刻。这家伙很有两下子。他不怯场，也不怕成为聚光灯的焦点。那是个疯狂的房间，我想确保表现得尊重一点，而且那真是一个美好的夜晚。感觉怎么样？
Was it long and boring or kind of fun? It was pretty short. Yeah. That's good. All right. Well, there it is. There it is. I tell you who's not short.
是又长又无聊还是挺好玩的？挺短的。那就好。好吧。事情就是这样。事情就是这样。我跟你说谁不短。
Oh, we got a tall guest coming in? I will say that this, she is an acclaimed actress, producer, and filmmaker, known for versatility, emotional, intelligent performances across film and television. Born in L.A., both her parents are acclaimed actors themselves. She started acting at a young age. She has been in some of my favorite movies of all time. And I'm also love, and I've had the honor. of being in a movie with her.
哦，我们要迎来一位高个子嘉宾吗？我要说的是，她是一位备受赞誉的演员、制作人和电影人，以其在电影和电视中多变的、充满情感和智慧的表演而闻名。出生于洛杉矶，她的父母本身都是备受赞誉的演员。她很小就开始演戏。她出演过我历来最喜欢的一些电影。而且我也很爱，并且我有幸能和她一起拍过电影。
We saw her in Blue Velvet, Wild at Heart. Laura Dern. First Academy War Domination, she won an Academy of... Look at this, huh? Look at the seamless tie-in we got here. I was going to say she's our friend, Laura Dern. Oh, my gosh.
我们在《蓝丝绒》、《我心狂野》中见过她。劳拉·邓恩。第一位获得奥斯卡提名的，她获得过奥斯卡……看看这个，哈？看看我们这天衣无缝的串场。我本来想说她我们的朋友，劳拉·邓恩。哦，天哪。
I can't wait to drill you about just the torches of working with Will Arnett. What is your least favorite part of working with it? First of all, no, no, hang on. Before we get into her least favorite part, because she has a lot of least favorite parts. I will say, Laura, I love, I can see in the reflection of your window,
我已经迫不及待要盘问你和威尔·阿奈特合作的痛苦经历了。你最不喜欢和他合作的哪一点？首先，不，不，等等。在我们探讨她最不喜欢的部分之前，因为她最不喜欢的部分有很多。我得说，劳拉，我喜欢，我能从你窗户的倒影里看到，
the fire, the fire going. I mean, guys, and it wasn't even planned. In LA, with a fire going to be the coziest episode ever. It's so cozy. But by the way, has every single guest ever told you that the hardest acting job of their life is staying quiet while you're hysterical? And all I want to talk about is Sean and Scotty as parents?
壁炉，生着火的壁炉。我的天哪，而且这甚至都不是计划好的。在洛杉矶，伴着壁炉，这绝对是有史以来最温馨的一集。太温馨了。不过话说回来，是不是每个嘉宾都跟你说过，他们演艺生涯中最艰难的工作就是在你歇斯底里的时候保持安静？而我只想聊聊肖恩和斯科蒂当父母的事？
What? That's my dream. This is your time. This is your turn. Go get him. Talk it into it. Laura, give him a good pitch because you've got a great kid or two. Two great kids and she's such a great.
什么？那是我的梦想。这是你的时间。轮到你了。上吧，拿下他。聊这个。劳拉，给他出个好主意，因为你有一个或两个好孩子。两个好孩子，而且她本身就那么棒。
You guys know. Tell Sean how great he'd be and age is not a factor. I don't know. It's not a factor and I liked the Citizen Kane imagery. I sort of like in the wheelchair of Sean of rolling into parents, his preschooler. Yeah, they're only going to be 10 years old before they have to wipe me. I like the idea of you, Sean,
你们都知道。告诉肖恩他会是个多么棒的父亲，年龄不是问题。我不知道。这不是问题，我喜欢《公民凯恩》式的意象。我有点喜欢肖恩坐在轮椅上，把他的学龄前儿童推向父母的画面。是啊，他们才十岁大就得帮我擦屁股了。我喜欢这样的画面，你，肖恩，
have you, Scotty, and your child eating at one end of a huge, like, 30-person table. Yeah. Right, and a butler coming in. I'll finish her homework. No, the three of you at Dupar's, I'm just so... Oh, my God, DuPas. I'm just so happy.
你、斯科蒂和你们的孩子在一张巨大的、比如三十人长桌的一端吃饭。对吧，然后管家走进来。我来写完她的作业。不，你们三个在杜帕斯餐厅，我简直太……哦，天哪，杜帕斯。我简直太高兴了。
Wait, so for Tracy, who may not know, I think she knows, well, Will and Laura star in the upcoming is this thing on, And Sean Hayes co-stars. And Sean Hayes and Scott Ice Noggle as well. That's correct. We're both in it as well. Who's incredible in this movie. He's great.
等等，所以对于特雷西来说可能不知道，我想她知道，威尔和劳拉主演了即将上映的电影《这玩意儿开着吗？》，而肖恩·海耶斯也参演了。肖恩·海耶斯和斯科特·伊森格尔也参演了。没。错。我们俩也都在里面。谁在这部电影里表现得不可思议。他太棒了。
I will talk about Sean and Will as well, but I have to start with Scotty. Scottie has one of my favorite lines in the movie, Laura, in that scene, all of us are in that scene and they say, I want to raise a toes to somebody who's done a great thing. You're just got to go, thank you. All right, exactly, exactly.
我也会聊到肖恩和威尔，但我必须从斯科蒂开始。斯科蒂在电影里有一句我最喜欢的台词，劳拉，在那场戏里，我们所有人都在那场戏里，他们说，我要为做了一件伟大事情的人举杯。你只要说，谢谢。好吧，没错，没错。
Oh, my gosh. Where was that great apartment? That was an awesome apartment. Oh, my God, that was... In Dumbo, right? That was in Dumbo. That was... Yeah, that was Bradley and Andrew Day's apartment, their characters.
哦，天哪。那间绝佳的公寓在哪里？那是一间超级棒的公寓。哦，天哪，那是……在登波（Dumbo），对吧？那是在登波。那是……是的，那是布拉德利和安德鲁·戴的公寓，他们角色的公寓。
Yeah. It was a great apartment. Well, they turned it into a great apartment. Yeah, yeah. Laura, I just saw you in another great movie yesterday, Jay Kelly. Jay Kelly. Nice going. Oh, I want to see that.
是的，那是一间很棒的公寓。好吧，他们把它变成了一间很棒的公寓。对，对。劳拉，我昨天刚在另一部很棒的电影里看到你，《杰·凯利》。《杰·凯利》。干得好。哦，我想看那个。
Thank you. I want to see that. This is what I want to see. She doesn't really waste her... She doesn't waste her time in bad stuff, guys. No, I know. When's the last time you saw her in a bad project? You can't challenge you.
谢谢。我想看那个。这就是我想看的。她可不怎么浪费她的……她不会在烂片上浪费时间，伙计们。对，我知道。你上次看她演烂片是什么时候？你根本挑不出毛病。
It doesn't exist. Okay, if you wanted to be a challenge. So, Laura, how do you pick projects? Is it script director, is there an order? Or like what speaks to you as the role and you don't care about the other stuff? Or how do you pick? I guess first I ask if any of you are in it. Sure.
根本不存在。好吧，如果你想挑刺的话。那么，劳拉，你是如何挑选项目的？是剧本、导演，有什么先后顺序吗？还是说角色本身吸引了你，你根本不在乎其他的事情？或者你是怎么挑选的？我想首先我会问你们中间有没有人参演。当然。
And then if I'm lucky. You got two out of three on the last one. By the way, three out of three because, and it always interests me, it's people that come up to me that no specific films that I'm in that they love have seen me over the years mention a few of the films they're grateful for
然后如果我很幸运的话。上一部你中了两个。顺便说一句，中了三个，因为，这总是让我很感兴趣，总有人跑过来对我说，他们喜欢我参演的哪些特定电影，他们多年来一直看我的戏，还提到了几部他们心存感激的电影，
and then also tell me how much they love me in Ozark and I'm like is because my name is Laura you're confusing this is it just the Laura connection but Laura Linney will also tell you this really you guys get stopped for each other
然后还会告诉我他们有多么喜欢我在《黑钱胜地》里的表演，而我就想，是因为我的名字叫劳拉吗？你搞混了，这只是劳拉效应吗？但劳拉·琳妮也会这么告诉你，真的，你们俩总被认错。
yeah yeah really so I kind of so we've worked together as well I can see the people make that brain fart and they're like I loved you in Ozark with Justin Bateman Yeah Yeah yeah yeah
对，对，真的。所以我有点，所以我们也合作过，我能看出人们脑子会短路，然后他们就会说，我在《黑钱胜地》里太喜欢你了，搭档杰森·贝特曼。对，对，对，对。
That covers all the bases Yeah Laura you started Listen we're going to get Into choosing rules Well first of all You can answer Sean's question
这涵盖了所有的基本面。对。劳拉，你开始，听着，我们一会儿要聊到挑选角色。不过首先，你可以回答肖恩的问题。
What is your criteria Is there a process? Yeah I would say that I Could you choose well Thank you I One have gotten
你的标准是什么？有什么流程吗？对，我会说，我，你选得很好。谢谢。我一向。
Very blessed to be chosen So I don't know that I think it's more about luck than the choosing. And if we are lucky, and as our careers evolve, we maybe get to do some of the choosing. But when I was a kid and getting to watch my parents work with incredible filmmakers, I didn't know what was happening. I was just a six, seven-year-old kid on set. I fell in love with their relationship with filmmakers and what that felt.
非常幸运能被选中。所以我不知道这与其说是我在挑选，不如说是靠运气。如果我们足够幸运，随着我们职业生涯的发展，我们也许能有一些选择权。但当我还是个孩子，有机会看着我的父母与不可思议的电影人合作时，我根本不知道发生了什么。我只是片场一个六七岁的小女孩。我爱上了他们与电影人的关系，以及那种感觉：
like to see people understand or have an instinct about my parent in a way that I felt I knew them intimately, things that others didn't know about them. And I thought, man, this is such a crazy dynamic that there are these people that get them in a way they may not even have caught up to in themselves. So I sort of fell in love with that relationship before I even understood what acting was like. And so I always dreamt of getting to work with master filmmakers. And, you know, I got lucky at a young age
看到人们以一种我觉得自己能够深刻理解的方式去理解我的父母，或者对我的父母有一种直觉，那些别人并不了解他们的事情。我想，天哪，这真是一种奇妙的动态关系，竟然有这样一群人，他们对他们的理解甚至超过了他们自己对自己的认识。所以，甚至在我真正理解什么是表演之前，我就已经爱上了那种关系。因此，我一直梦想着能与大师级的电影人合作。而且，你知道我很幸运，在很小的时候，
that extraordinary directors, you know, hired me. But did you, did you, do you remember filmmakers being around the house, like filmmakers that we know, filmmakers, like, do you remember that? Oh, yeah, I remember when I was six, my summer vacation, that became the year that I then went to my parents and said, I wanted to start studying acting, and became kind of obsessed with the idea of it, which seems so absurd now
那些非凡的导演就录用了我。但是你，你，你还记得家里经常有电影人出没吗，比如我们认识的电影人，导演之类的，你还记得吗？哦，记得，我六岁的时候，那个暑假成了我后来去找我父母说我想开始学习表演的一年，并且开始对这个想法有点着迷，现在看来这简直太荒谬了，
but I just knew I guess, you know, there are things you know about that you loved. But my mom was doing, Alice doesn't live here anymore with Martin Scorsese and my dad was doing a film
但我当时就是知道，我想，你知道的，有些事情你知道你就是很喜欢。但我妈妈当时正在拍马丁·斯科塞斯的《爱丽丝不住在这里》，我爸爸在拍一部电影，
family plot with Alfred Hitchcock and I went back and forth between those two sets. So for my sister who might not know, your dad is Bruce Stern and your mom is Diane Ladd who I'm sorry just recently passed him. So sorry, but she was fantastic.
阿尔弗雷德·希区柯克的《大巧局》，我在那两个片场之间跑来跑去。所以对于可能不知道这一点的我妹妹来说，你爸爸是布鲁斯·邓恩，你妈妈是黛安·拉德，我很难过她最近刚去世。非常遗憾，但她太棒了。
Yeah. Same. Thank you. Yeah. So, yeah. It was an amazing thing. Just like watching these, you know, mind-blowing directors at work with them.
是的。我也是。谢谢。是的。所以，是的。那真是一件神奇的事。就像看着这些，你知道的，令人脑洞大开的导演与他们合作。
And then, you know, yeah, as a kid, Hal Ashby was my dad's neighbor as well as a colleague and, you know, became such a hero director to me and a lot of directors. Do you do something in Allison? It doesn't live here anymore? I was an extra. Yeah. I ate an ice cream cone. and I had to, I think they did like 16 takes or something,
然后，你知道的，是的，作为一个孩子，哈尔·阿什比既是我爸爸的邻居也是同事，而且，你知道的，他成了我和很多导演心目中的英雄导演。你在《爱丽丝不住在这里》里演过什么吗？我演了个群众演员。对。我吃了一个冰淇淋甜筒，
so I had to eat 16 ice cream cones. And Marty said to my mom, Sean, they're not still casting, by the way. Yeah, yeah, yeah. As Sean said, he's been paid for licking before. Oh, my God. I thought it was going to be a leader host. Sometimes for free.
我不得不，我想他们拍了大约16条左右，所以我就得吃16个冰淇淋甜筒。马蒂对妈妈说，肖恩，顺便说一句，他们可没在选角了。对，对，对。正如肖恩所说，他以前舔东西也是拿过片酬的。天哪。我还以为会是个领衔主演。有时是免费的。
But he had sort of commented in front of me to my mom, like, oh my God, she just ate 16 ice cream cones, and she didn't throw up. Like, that kid's going to be an actress. That's hilarious. Oh, someone got me. Do you have any recall at all about what kind of person Alfred Hitchcock was? Yeah.
但他当着我的面跟我妈评论说，天哪，她刚刚吃了16个冰淇淋甜筒，居然没吐。这孩子以后肯定能成个演员。太搞笑了。哦，有人抓到我了。你对阿尔弗雷德·希区柯克是个什么样的人还有什么记忆吗？是的。
Guys, the craziest thing, I remember, you know, because there's all kinds of stories, you know, reputationally about him. But all I know is I was super little and a bit intimidated anyway whenever I went on set. I always thought I was in the way and kind of shy. and he had props make a mini director's chair that he put next to him and let me sit there with him.
伙计们，最疯狂的是，我记得，你知道的，因为关于他的名声有各种各样的故事。但我所知道的是，我当时超级小，而且每当我走进片场时总是有点被吓到。我总是觉得自己碍手碍脚的，而且有点害羞，
No way. Somebody took a picture of that. You know what? I have one photo with them on set but not in the director's chairs, which is crazy. Just sitting next to him. And I didn't know, all I knew was, you know,
他让道具师做了一把迷你导演椅放在他旁边，让我跟他一起坐在那儿。绝不可能。有人拍下那张照片了吗？你知道吗？我有一张和他在片场但不在导演椅上的合影，这也很疯狂。就是坐在他旁边。我不知道，我只知道，你知道，
it was this man who would, yeah, like laugh hysterically at my dad. He thought my dad was so funny. and I just loved that because at the time people would come up to me telling me what a bad guy my dad was because he'd killed John Wayne.
就是这个人，他会，是的，比如听我爸爸讲笑话笑得前仰后合。他觉得我爸爸太搞笑了，我真的很喜欢那样，因为当时人们会跑来告诉我，我爸爸是个多坏的人，因为他在电影里杀了约翰·韦恩。
And for your sister, my dad was, I think, the only person to successfully kill John Wayne in a movie. So he was not very well liked at the time but loved for being a bad guy in Westerns, but also as a kid, you're sort of intimidated by people talking about
对于你的妹妹来说，我爸爸似乎是唯一一个在电影里成功杀死约翰·韦恩的人。所以他当时不怎么讨人喜欢，但因为在西部片里演坏人而备受喜爱，不过作为一个孩子，你难免会被那些议论声吓到，
like, oh, man, do I love to hate you? I was like, oh, okay. Enjoy your time at Disney. New Zealand, Sean Hayes is with his child. Right. No, he was too tired to go. Yes, the man in the wheelchair. Yeah, exactly.
比如，哦，天哪，我有多么恨你却又忍不住爱你？我就想，哦，好吧。享受你在迪士尼的时光吧。新西兰，肖恩·海耶斯正和他的孩子在一起。对。不，他太累了，没去。是的，那个坐轮椅的人。对，没错。
Brum, brim, brum. Did you ever feel any sort of, or did you start too early to feel any sort of intellectual pressure to, to work as consistently as your parents have? Like, that's, that's a, those are real tall bars to try to match, jump over, live up to. I mean, you've made. This is such a question for you as well, and I will say one thing I so love every time I get to see Jason because of our shared friends is I find you and we find a corner and then we just go. And we share growing up amidst family at young ages working amidst other family members. Did you guys ever cross paths when you were young?
轰，轰，轰。你有没有感受到任何，或者说你出道太早，以至于感受到任何智力上的压力，去达到你父母那样始终如一的高产？真的，那些都是极高的标杆，很难去匹配、跨越、不负期望。我的意思是，你已经。这也是一个很适合你的问题，而且我要说一件事，每次因为我们有共同的朋友而见到杰森时我都超级喜欢，我发现你和我们会找一个角落然后就开始聊。我们分享着在年幼时身处演艺世家、在其他家庭成员身边工作的成长经历。你们小时候有没有交集？
Did you guys have Hollywood friends in common? I don't think so, no. No, no, Laura was, you know, the whole stratosphere higher than... Don't you dare. No, the stratosphere, to me, was yours. I could, you know, doing the things I was obsessed. But living up to what your parents are so immensely famous your entire life, were you even conscious that you were setting yourself up to, like,
你们有什么共同的好朋友在好莱坞吗？我想没有，没有。没有，没有，劳拉当时，你知道的，比……高出好几个境界。你敢。不，在我看来，那个境界是你的。我能，你知道的，做那些让我着迷的事情。但要一直不负你父母一生中如此巨大的名气，你从小到大，甚至有没有意识到你在给自己设定这样的目标：
how could I ever live up to that? Or that never got in your way, did it? No, I feel like I was so young that it was only later. that any of that occurred to me or I probably never would have done it. But before you said for any kids out there that do struggle with that, like, thank God you didn't let it get in your way
我怎么可能不负期望？还是说这从来没妨碍过你，对吧？不，我觉得我当时太小了，这些事都是后来才意识到的，否则我可能永远都不会去做了。但正如你之前说的，对于那些为此苦恼的孩子们，谢天谢地，你没有让它妨碍你，
because it shouldn't. Because it is, you are a completely individual person separate from your parents, you know, even though you may want to go into the same occupation as them, whether it's acting or not, like it's completely natural. that a kid would want to go down the same lane they've watched and admired
因为本该如此。因为你是一个完全独立的个体，独立于你的父母，你知道的，尽管你可能想从事和他们相同的职业，不管是表演还是别的什么，这完全是很自然的，
because your parents are your first heroes. And so why wouldn't you want to go and do the same thing that they were doing? And it doesn't matter whether you end up doing the same accomplishments that they do. It's just, I don't know. I just think, I think kids get a bad rap. And most professions we know
一个孩子会想走他们看过并崇拜的那条路，因为你的父母是你的第一批英雄。所以你为什么不想去从事他们做过的事情呢？而且你最终是否能达到他们那样的成就不重要。这只是，我不知道。我只是觉得，孩子们背负了太多骂名。我们知道大多数行业，
only kind of revere legacy families or going into the family business. business, your butcher, a doctor you go to. By the way, knowing your kids, they're just hilarious, brilliant people. And I just can't wait for them to write and direct and act if they choose it because it's innate in them. And Will and I had an amazing experience because working on our movie, which I will get into and divulge all these beautiful things about will sorry guys i'm going to be super reverent about will it's going to be a bummer for you both but we like him but we'll we also got to work with Peyton manning and when Peyton and i had a scene
都只崇尚家族世袭或者继承家族企业，比如你的屠夫，你去看病的医生。顺便说一句，了解你们的孩子就知道，他们都是些滑稽、聪明的人。我简直迫不及待地想看他们写作、导演和表演，如果他们选择这条路的话，因为这是他们刻在骨子里的天分。我和威尔有过一次奇妙的经历，因为在拍摄我们的电影时，我等会儿会深入探讨并倾诉所有关于威尔的美好事情，对不起伙计们，我对威尔将充满崇敬，这可能会让你们俩觉得扫兴，但我们都很喜欢他，而且我们还和佩顿·曼宁一起工作过，当时佩顿和我有一场对手戏，不知怎么的，就谈到了所谓“星二代”这个话题，他说，对啊，我就是个星二代，然后我想，哦对了，从没有人去谈论那些伟大的NFL橄榄球世家，不会说像佩顿·曼宁就不该进这一行。伊利·曼宁应该去干点别的。这太疯狂了。而且还有一件事。如果人们不想要这些，不管怎样，他们就不会有机会。事情就是这样运作的。我们知道它是怎么运作的。不管怎样，归根结底还是商业利益，对吧？在任何行业里。如果一个人说，我爸是个医生，我决定当个医生，而他是个烂医生，他就不会有病人。事情就是这样。我们这行也一样。所以我觉得，但这很容易，
together and somehow this subject of quote nepo babies came up and he's like yeah i'm a nepo baby and i thought oh right no one ever talks about you know legacy like the great NFL family of all time and say like Peyton Manning shouldn't have done it. Eli Manning should have done something else. It's so crazy. And here's the other thing. If people didn't want it, whatever, then they wouldn't have opportunity. That's just the way that it works.
成为众矢之的，正如你所看到的，因为这一切都太公开了，所以这就你知道的，是的。但正如你所说，如果你没有真本事，如果你是个星二代却没本事，你就没法干，你根本无法混下去，你知道吗，肖恩，我刚刚意识到，这就是你和斯科特应该做的，你们应该生一个星二代。对，对，对，去领养一个星二代，给孩子起名叫内波（Nepo），这真是一个绝妙的主意。对，对，对，我不能带他去儿科，他说，内波，内波·贝イビー·海耶斯。这是我们的儿子，内波。内波，伊森格尔。
We know how it works. It all boils down to commerce anyway, right? In any business. If the guy goes, if he's like, my dad was a doctor and I decided to become a doctor and he was a shit doctor, he wouldn't have any patients. Like that's just the way it goes. It's the same in our business. So I do, but it's an easy.
我们立刻让他上了一档节目。让他进娱乐圈。对，对，对。真人秀节目。寻找内波。当然。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。劳拉，第一件，
target as you see because it's so it's so public so it's just you know yeah but if you like you said if you don't have the goods if you're a nepo baby you don't have the goods it doesn't you can't like you don't work you know what shana just realized that's what you and scot should have you should have a nepo baby yeah yeah yes adopt a nepo baby name the baby nepo that that's a great a great idea yeah yeah yeah i can't take him to the pediatrics he's like Nepo, Nepo Baby, Hayes. This is our son, Nepo. Nepo, Issenuggle.
第一份工作是什么，你当时，首先我想说，说到父母的事情，JB，我不知道你知不知道，当年你和你妈妈是历史上第一对，呃，母女，孩子和父母同时被提名的。
We got him in a show right away. Get him into a show. Yeah, yeah. A reality show. Finding Nepo. Sure. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Laura, what was the first,
凭借我深爱的电影《激情蔷薇》双双获得奥斯卡提名，劳拉，你在那部电影里表现得不可思议，我要让你难堪了，因为我太爱你了我不知道你们俩竟然在同一年、同一部电影里获得提名。
what was the first, job where you were you well first of all I want to do I do want to say talking about the parent stuff jb I don't know if you know this when you and your mom were the first time ever uh child mother daughter child parent were nominate both
对，同一部电影。对，哇。在同一个类别里吗？
Academy Award nominations for Rambling Rose a film that I adore it's an you're incredible in that movie Laura and I'm going to embarrass you because I just love you so much I didn't know that both of you got nominated the same year same movie yeah the same movie yeah wow in the same category
不，不同的类别。一个是最佳女配角，一个是最佳女主。哇。太疯狂了。这不是很不可思议吗？对。对。那你去了吗？
No, separate categories. One was supporting, one was lead. Wow. That's a wild. Isn't that incredible? Yeah. Yeah. And did you go?
你去了吗？你们拼车去的吗？我们和我奶奶一起去的。太甜了。不会吧。太棒了。有多棒？这太疯狂了。
Did you go? Did you carpool? We went together with my grandma. It was so sweet. No way. It was amazing. How great is that? It was crazy.
太美妙了。真的太疯狂了。劳拉，你做的第一件让你觉得，比如你拥有的第一个角色，你演完之后觉得，比如，我搞定了。倒不是说我搞定了，而是你感觉真的很好。你觉得和它产生了真正的连接。就像第一部那种有分量的作品，让你觉得，好吧，
It was so beautiful. So, so crazy. What was, Laura, what was the first thing that you did where you felt like, like the first role that you had that you did and you were like, Like, I got it. Not I got it, but you felt really good. Like you feel really connected to it. Like the first sort of meaty thing that you're like, okay,
这真的是我想做的事，而且感觉很好。你有过那种经历吗？对，也许是这部电影《无言的对话》。这大概是我的第一部大女主戏，所以我根本没有时间不去全身心投入。你知道的，就像我们拍摄这部电影，
like this is really what I want to do and it feels good. Did you have one of those? Yeah, maybe this movie Smooth Talk. It was probably my first lead, and so I had no time to not find devotion. You know, like it was, we made. for under $2 million. I was in every scene.
成本不到200万美元。我每一场戏都在。这是一部非常激进的电影，由我和特里特·威廉斯主演。其中有一场长达半小时、非常令人不安且拍摄起来极其复杂的戏，讲述了一个年轻女孩在乔伊斯·卡罗尔·奥茨的故事基础上被诱导走向性侵的过程。
It was a really radical film with myself and Treat Williams. There's a very deeply troubling and very complicated to shoot half hour long kind of coaxing of this young girl toward a sexual assault based on a Joyce Carol Oates story.
而且，你知道的，有着巨量的台词，你知道，扮演一个角色，而我拍这部电影时只有15岁，她有点在探索自己的性意识，而那时我对自我的很多方面还懵懂无知，
And, you know, radical amounts of dialogue and, you know, playing a character and I was 15 when we made it who's sort of discovering her sexuality a bit before I knew so many aspects of self.
我还没有那么完全地了解自己，我必须，是的，我必须在情感上极度脆弱，同时还要不知怎么地学会照顾好自己，是的，我想那是第一次我不得不表现得像个成年人。电影拍完之后，或者在经历特别艰难的一天之后，
I didn't know myself in that way so completely and I had to, yeah, I had to be so emotionally vulnerable and still somehow learn how to take care of myself and, yeah, that was the first time I think I had to be a grown-up. And after the film was done or after that particularly hard day
当你拍完一场特别艰难的戏时，你什么时候会觉得，哇，我刚刚斩杀了一条恶龙，我已经挺过来了？我直接进入了一种愤世嫉俗的状态，就像个饱经沧桑、47岁抽着烟的离婚老女人。我就会想，我已经完成了，你知道的，现在我可以只做一个贵妇了。
when you did a particularly hard scene, when did you feel like, wow, I just kind of slayed that dragon and I'm on the other side of it? I just went straight to like cynical, like jaded, divorcee, 47-year-old smoker. I just like, I've done the, you know, now I get to just be a dame.
不，其实不是。但你什么时候，你会不会觉得在电影结束时、或者那天结束时、或者影片上映并获得反响时，你已经挺过来了？你知道吗？我觉得最酷的事情是，我记得在一整天都在哭泣之后，我真的给家里打了电话，给我妈妈打了电话，心想也许这并不是最有趣的工作。也许这并不是，就像我并不理解所有这些情绪以及该把它们放在哪里，而我当时，
No, not really. But when did you, did you, but did you feel that you were on the other, the side of it at the end of the movie or at the end of that day or once it came out and it got received? You know what? I think the coolest thing was I remember actually calling home and calling my mom after just a day of crying all day and thinking maybe this isn't the most fun job. Maybe this isn't, like I didn't understand all these feelings and where to put them and I was
很幸运能有可以谈论这些事的父母，并且能够从中抽离出来，学会虽然这是情感的宣泄，你可以打开所有这些空间，但你并不一定要活在其中。这可以是一种治愈的过程，是通往治愈的工作，而不是某种以奇怪的方式将你撕裂的东西。但你觉得你成功做到了，对吧？
blessed to have parents I could talk to about that. and get some distance from things and learn how to, even though it's emotional, and you can kind of crack open all these spaces, you don't have to, like, live in it. It can be healing and a job toward healing and not something that kind of rips you apart in some weird way. But you felt that you'd pulled it off, yeah?
眼泪是可信的，诸如此类的。对，我觉得，我觉得，我当时觉得有点害怕，因为这不是刻意为之的。我并不是在试图成为一个方法派演员。我只是一个刚好哭了一整天的孩子，我的身体就像哭了一整天之后那样颤抖且疲惫不堪。所以我想，正是达到了那样一个境界，在那一天的结束时，我明白了什么是自我，什么是另一个充满发现的游戏空间。而我认为最深的快乐发生在那个时期前后，也在《蓝丝绒》里，这两部戏相隔大约一年半。
The tears were believable and all that. Yeah, I felt, I felt, I think I felt a little scared by it because it wasn't intentional. I wasn't trying to be a method actor. I was a kid who just had a day of crying all day and my body was like shaking and unhappy like when you've cried all day. And so I think just the getting to the place where at the end of that day I learned kind of what was me and what was this other play space of discovery. And I think the deepest joy which happened around that time and also on Blue Velvet, which were like a year and a half apart.
那是我生命中的几年，我发现了同理心这件像绝招一样的超能力。对。那种敞开心扉、充满同理心、成为一个团队一部分的感觉，在那里你们只是向彼此敞开心扉。而且这一切有望是安全和慷慨的。还能打动观众。这太激进也太硬核了，
Those were a couple years in my life where I discovered empathy as this, like, badass superpower. Yeah. That being vulnerable and being empathetic and being part of a, you know, a team of people where you're just going to kind of reveal yourself to each other. And it's going to somehow be hopefully safe and generous. And move an audience. It was like so radical and hardcore. baller.
大佬风范。你知道的，我感觉，是的，就像一个刚刚找到一项运动的孩子。对。这确实很诡异。这真的是世界上最疯狂的事情，坐在那里，满口谎言却能让自己哭出来。对。而且可能还能让看的人哭出来。大家都心照不宣地在玩过家家。
You know, I felt, yeah, I felt like a kid who just found a sport. Yeah. It is weird. It is just like, it's the craziest thing in the world to sit there and be so full of shit that you can make yourself cry. Yeah. And probably make the person watching cry. And like everybody's on board that we're playing make believe.
做这件事的人在过家家，而我在假装它是真的，以至于我在看的时候自己都哭了。就像所有人都认可这样荒诞的时刻：我们一起走进这个黑漆漆的房间，坐在这些陌生人旁边，彼此挨着哭泣，然后离开，上车开车回家，
The people that are doing it are in make-believe and I'm pretending that it's real so much so that it's making me cry while I'm watching it. Like everyone signs on to this like bizarro moment that we all go in this dark room together and sit next to these strangers, cry next to one another, and then go leave, get in our car and drive home
想想今晚吃什么。我知道。这简直是最酷、最诡异的事情了。对。但在某种程度上，我简直难以置信。听到你这么说，J.B.，你就会明白，这一切其实都只关于我们都渴望连接，我们都只想，比如，彼此连接并拥有这些共同的体验，
and have what's for dinner. I know. It's just like the coolest, weirdest thing. Yeah. But it's so, on a certain level, I can't believe it. Hearing you say it that way, J.B., you realize it is all just about we all just want to connect and we all just want to, like, connect with each other and have these shared experiences
因为这其中的某些东西，它激励着我们，它让我们，我们能与之产生共鸣。人生对人们来说真的很有趣。对，对。你知道的，就像，来看看这些生活的碎片。然后你会想，好吧，你会去，你知道的，在它最伟大的一面时，当你去看到某种能以那种方式触动你的事物时，对它产生这种情感上的连接或者拥有这种共同的体验，
because something about that, it inspires us, it makes us, we can relate to it. Life's really interesting to people. Yeah, yeah. You know, like, let's see these little pieces. And you go, well, you go and you, you know, at its greatest, when you go and you see something that kind of moves you in that way, having that emotional connection to that or having that shared experience,
甚至不仅仅是和影院里的人，而是当你观看时没有出现的人，我想，这也是我第一次意识到这一点，也许我只是学东西比较慢。这里面确实有些东西，就像，它某种程度上在我们内心激起了波澜，让我们，给我们对自身经历的审视带来了视角，
not even just with the people in the theater, but the people aren't when you're watching it, I guess, and it's just occurring to me for the first time, maybe I'm just a slow learner. It does, there's something about it that, like, it sort of, it stirs something in us and makes us sort of, gives us perspective on our own experience,
它某种程度上解答了我们自身经历中的种种疑问，诸如此类的事情。我认为这照亮了人类的精神，如果你这么说的话。尽管听起来像是一堆废话，但我今天其实真的这么认为了。我在看《原力觉醒》时都哭了。对，我敢打赌你肯定哭了。
and it sort of answers questions about our own experience, and all that kind of stuff. I think it's illuminating to the human spirit, if you will. As bullshit as that sounds, I really actually believe that now today. I cried at Force Awakens. Yeah, I'll bet you did.
好吧，是的。是放映机坏了还是怎么的？没有。你是坐在一个戴帽子的人后面还是怎么的？你把爆米花洒了吗？没有瓶盖。他们卖完了牛奶？但这确实很疯狂，
Well, yeah. Did the projector break or something? No. Were you sitting behind somebody with a hat or something? Did you spill your bombolans? With no caps. They ran out of milkouts? But it is crazy.
你知道的，你无法伪造真实。你可以伪造很多事情。你们作为优秀的演员以及导演都很清楚，还有另一件事会发生，那就是当我们触及一件事的真相时，我们所有人都会共同感受到那种东西。那是无法伪造的。但与此同时，
that, you know, you can't fake truth. You could fake a lot of things. And you guys all know as incredible actors and also as directors that there's this other thing that happens that we all feel together when we get to the truth of a thing. And it can't be faked. But like at the same time,
我们都在假装它不是假的。就像，我们知道它是假的，而我们都只是在说，好吧，让我们都同意高度集中注意力，以至于我们能够说服自己、我们的泪腺和一切，这都是真的。就像，我喜欢每个人都只是默默地，
we're all pretending that it isn't fake. Like, we know that it's. it's fake, and we're all just saying, okay, let's all agree to focus so hard that we can convince ourselves and our tear ducks and everything that this is real. Like, I love that everybody just kind of silently
接受这一点，而且大家甚至互不相识。对，对，对。但在那些时刻，它就是真的。这就是事情奇妙的翻转之处，J.B.。好吧，这就是电影的魅力所在。我们马上回来。哦，对不起。该死，肖恩的麦克风在工作。
signs on to that, and no one knows each other. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But in those moments, it is real. That's the kind of the flip of it. J.B. Well, that's the magic of movies. We'll be right back. Oh, I'm sorry. Shit, Sean's mic is working.
真该死。嘿，我刚才在看J.B.的视频，真奇怪，在Instagram上，大卫·克劳斯发布了一个《发展受阻》的片段。我在看……哦，哦，不，我看到我在做单口喜剧。不，你当时在演早期的一场戏，你和大卫还有波西亚有一场对手戏。你身上有些东西……
God damn. Hey, I was watching J.B., weirdly enough, on Instagram, David Cross posted a clip from Arrest of the Elmint. And I was watching... Oh, oh, no, I saw I'm doing stand-up. No, and you were doing a scene from early on, you were doing a scene with David and Portia. And there was something about you...
我看着你演这场戏。而你……他们俩都表现得像白痴一样。所以你夹在他们中间。我完全沉浸在你的节奏里。你太棒了。你把我带入了那种情境。虽然我对它烂熟于心。
I was watching you do this scene. And you were... And they're both acting like imbeciles. And so you're in the middle between them. And I was so on the ride with you. You were such a great. You took me on this thing. And I know it inside and out.
但我依然深深地被它吸引。看你表演。虽然演的不是你，杰伊。但你当时在做这件事。它逗笑了我。它让我感觉良好。而且我和它在更深的层面上产生了连接。但它只是让我爱上了你。
And yet I was still really taking with it. You doing it. And it's not you, Jay. But you were doing this thing. And it made me laugh. And it made me feel good. And I had a connection to it on a deeper level as well. But it just made me love you.
当时我就想，操，看看这家伙。他太擅长这个了。我太喜欢了。为什么人们要说那些关于它的刻薄话呢？好吧，是的，如果我们相信了，那观众就会相信。劳拉，你，你有一个……哦，该死，抱歉，我提到了肖恩。
And I was just like, fuck, look at this guy. He's so good at doing this. I love that. Why do people say all those nasty things about it? Well, yeah, if we believe it, then the audience will believe it. Laura, do you, you had a... Oh, shit, sorry, I mentioned Sean.
肖恩炉子上正煮着意大利面和肉丸，所以他得赶紧回答他的问题。不，我……顺便说一句，我刚说……我刚用什么配着吃的中餐？一杯牛奶，因为太辣了。等一下，现在才4点30分。你什么意思？
Sean's got a spaghetti meatballs that's on the stove, and so he's got to get to his questions quick. No, I... By the way, I just said... I just said Chinese with what did I have to drink? A glass of milk, because it was too spicy. Hang on, it's 4.30. What do you mean?
不，现在是7点30分。他在纽约。哦，你在纽约。对，有……有时差。顺便说一句，TB，我之前和她通过FaceTime。我们三个通过了一次FaceTime。
No, it's 7.30. He's in New York. Oh, you are in New York. Yeah, there's... Time done. By the way, TB, I had a face-time with it before. The three of us had a FaceTime. before our session year, Laura.
就在我们这期录制之前，劳拉。然后在此之前，肖恩和我大约在一小时前讨论过某事，然后我说，肖恩说，我得走了，我们在录节目之前得先吃东西。然后他说，我说，哦，好吧，那我不耽误你了。他说，我在吃中餐。这就过去了，好吧。每天吃晚饭对他的人生来说都是一件大事。我太喜欢了。
And then before that, Sean and I talked like an hour ago about something, and I go, and Sean goes, I got to go, I got to eat before we do the show. And he goes, and I go, oh, yeah, okay, I'll let you go. And he goes, I'm having Chinese. It went, okay. Every day dinner's an event in his life. I love that.
这太搞笑了。我好久没吃中餐了。劳拉，你喜欢中餐吗？我超爱。我也超爱。内波。
It was such a funny. I haven't had Chinese in so long. Laura, do you like Chinese food? I love it. I love it, too. Nepo. Nepo talks a lot about how much he loves Chinese.
内波经常说他有多爱中餐。他怎么都吃不够。我今晚想吃中餐。嘿，我保证这是我问的唯一一个关于《侏罗纪公园》的问题。但当我们正在片场……是真的吗？不，是《这玩意儿开着吗？》。我们当时在片场。
He can't get enough of it. I'd like Chinese tonight. Hey, I promise this is the only Jurassic Park question I'll ask. But when we were on the set of... Is it real? No, is this thing on? We were on the set.
你给我讲了一个超级棒的故事。你能快点讲一遍吗，因为实在太酷了？关于……你还记得是什么吗？是关于……哦，是第一天史蒂芬拿着大喇叭的那次吗？
You told me the greatest story. Can you just tell it really fast because it's so cool? Something about... Do you remember what it was? It was about... Oh, was it about Stephen with the megaphone the first day?
你跟我讲过最棒的一个故事。你能快点再讲一遍吗，因为太酷了？好像是关于……你还记得是什么吗？是关于……哦，是第一天拿着扩音器的斯蒂芬吗？
That's it. Yes, yes. Yeah, that we were, I mean, this was the first CGI movie, so all we knew was we were going on this journey and there was this new idea called CGI and there was this company called ILM Industrial Light Magic and, you know, Dennis Muran was this guy I met on set and they were talking about how they could paint an image on the computer and things might show up that aren't there in real life. And they would put an X on a piece of paper and put it in like an orange picker up into a tree and they stare at the X. And I kept thinking, this may really not work because it just seemed nuts that it was even possible.
就是这样。对，对。我是说，我们当时在拍第一部CGI电影，所以我们只知道我们要踏上这段旅程，有一个叫CGI的新概念，还有一家叫ILM（工业光魔）的公司。我是在片场认识丹尼斯·穆伦的，他们谈论着如何在电脑上绘制影像，有些现实中不存在的东西可能会显现出来。他们会在一张纸上画一个“X”，把它放进采摘橙子的起重机里伸到树上，然后大家盯着那个“X”。我当时一直在想，这可能真的行不通，因为这听起来太疯狂了，甚至都觉得不可能实现。
And it was the first day, I think it was like second or third day on set and it was the first day we were all there as a group and we're looking into the what was the raptor pen, I guess. And Sir Richard Attenborough is kind of giving us a tour of the park. And for the first time, we hear something that may be a roar in the distance. That's right. It's like your first hint of something.
那是第一天，我想大概是第二天还是第三天在片场，也是我们所有人第一次作为集体聚在一起。我们看着那个应该是迅猛龙围栏的地方。理查德·阿滕伯格爵士正在带我们参观公园。我们第一次听到了远处可能传来的吼声。没错。就像是对某种事物的最初暗示。
And we did the first take, and we were all like looking in the wrong direction and not responding at the right time. So he said, Stephen, we need help. I mean, yeah, nothing's there, but we need to hear it at the same moment. And he goes, oh, my God, of course, of course. And obviously we had to be scared to sell the things that aren't there. So Stephen was sitting at camera, and they rolled camera action. We're looking.
我们拍了第一条，结果我们都看错了方向，也没有在正确的时机做出反应。所以他说：“斯蒂芬，我们需要帮助。我是说，虽然什么都没有，但我们需要在同一时刻听到声音。”他说：“哦，天哪，当然，当然。”很显然，我们必须表现出害怕，才能让人相信那些不在场的东西。于是斯蒂芬坐在摄像机旁，他们喊了“摄像，开始”。我们看着。
We turn our heads. The moment's about to come. And Stephen takes a megaphone and goes, roar. Roar. Rar. And we all lost to that. I know. in that moment, this group of actors
我们转过头。关键时刻要来了。斯蒂芬拿起一个扩音器喊道：“吼！吼！吼！”我们所有人都被逗乐了。我知道。那一刻，这群演员
lived in each other, like, this is a disaster. That must have been like, wait, what are we doing? Like, what? So you're just going to go rar through the whole movie? You lost his privileges on the whole horn. It also occurs
都在心里犯嘀咕：“这简直是一场灾难。”当时大家一定在想：“等等，我们在干什么？什么？难道你要在整部电影里都‘吼’过去吗？”他失去了在整个号角上发号施令的特权。我也突然
to me, Laura, you've become like sort of like the emblem, like the sort of the icon for they always use that image of a person. Yes, for me. You're my icon. Yeah. Obviously. Yeah, you're my. But that thing of the big dinosaur coming up right up against your face and you're totally freaked out, that is like such an iconic.
想到，劳拉，你已经成为了某种象征，就像那种人们总会用到的标志性人物。没错，为了我。你就是我的偶像。当然。是的，你就是我的。但那种巨大的恐龙冲到你脸前，而你吓得魂飞魄散的画面，真的是太标志性了。
You know, they always include that. It's like a huge, when you see that, do you remember the day you were shooting? Do you remember where you were going through? Do you remember, like... You had the reaction, yeah. Yeah, that was crazy. And, I mean, it was amazing because the incredible Stan Winston had built animatronic puppets. So there was so much practical puppetry.
你知道的，他们总是会把这个画面剪进去。这可真是一个巨大的……当你看到那一幕时，你还记得拍摄的那天吗？你还记得当时经历了什么吗？你还记得……你有那种反应，对吧。是的，那太疯狂了。而且，这太令人惊叹了，因为了不起的斯坦·温斯顿制作了电子动画木偶。所以里面有大量的实景木偶戏。
That's a real head there. Oh, yeah. And it was, yeah, you cuss. I've heard of the crazy shot on this show. Like scary as fuck. Like nothing scary. Oh, shit. We don't use the fun.
那是颗真的脑袋。哦，是的。而且，没错，你爆粗口了。我听说过这部剧里那些疯狂的镜头。吓死人了。一点也不吓人。哦，该死。我们不用那个词。
Sorry, not from the women. I told me that too when I just said it again. Fuck. And a third time. Not from the women. But it's so scary. Those dinosaurs were terrible. Yeah, I mean, isn't it, I'm sorry if you get asked this all the time,
抱歉，女士们别介意。我刚说完，他又提醒了我一次。操。第三次了。女士们别介意。但它真的很吓人。那些恐龙太可怕了。是的，我是说，难道你不觉得——如果这个问题你被问过无数次，请原谅我——
but isn't it wild to be part of something that you had no idea what it was going to be, it was cutting edge technology, and now it spawned like, I don't know how many movies, it was part of like this massive movement in Hollywood that changed how they made movies. And you were the first person, you were part of it. That's just so cool. I'd made Wild at Heart, I guess like the year before, two years before, something like that. And so I told Nick Cage that I had been. offered this opportunity, and I was like, you know, I haven't read it yet, but all I know is
成为一部你完全不知道它会变成什么样、代表着尖端科技的作品的一部分，并且它现在衍生出了——我不知道多少部电影，它是好莱坞彻底改变电影制作方式的那场宏大运动的一部分，而你当时是第一批演员，你是其中的一部分，难道这不让人觉得疯狂吗？这真的太酷了。我大概是在前一年还是两年前拍了《我心狂野》。所以我告诉尼古拉斯·凯奇，我得到了
Stephen explained that I guess there's dinosaurs are going to come back to life. And there's a book, I'm going to read the book. And he goes, you don't have to know anything. Dinosaurus are going to come back to life. You have to do this movie. And I just remember Nick being the person who, yeah. made me know I had to say yes instantly, but for learning more. Wait, okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, Laura. So, Sean opened the door, and then you just mentioned while at heart. So first of all, it should be noted, Laura made, you made so many great movies with the incomparable David Lynch,
这个机会，我说：“你知道，我还没读剧本，但我只知道……”
who I know was a close friend of yours as well. And it was just, you know, one of the all-time greats. And the two of you had this great collaboration on all these great movies. First one being Blue Velvet, just talking about. for a second about how that came to be so good and met him on an audition um and what part was he reading for 17 and he was very good to be honest um but crazily i went in and we talked for i feel like 45 minutes with the casting director and david about everything and i never read for him. And the casting director had seen me in a couple of films and I guess recommended me,
斯蒂芬解释说恐龙要复活了。还有一本书，我要去读那本书。他说：“你什么都不用知道。恐龙都要复活了。你必须拍这部电影。”我只记得尼古拉斯是那个让我知道我必须立刻答应的人，不过为了了解更多……等等，好吧，等等，等等，等等，劳拉。肖恩刚打开门，然后你提到了《我心狂野》。首先需要指出的是，劳拉，你和无与伦比的大卫·林奇合作过那么多部伟大的电影，
but he, I don't think, had seen my acting yet. But he just had an instinct. And he was so a believer in following instinct. And it seemed to go well. I mean, I just was, you know, so in love with his movies already. So it was such a huge thing to me. I'd seen Eraserhead. I'd seen elephant man and so I was just blown away by him and then he invited myself and Kyle McLaughlin to lunch at Bob's Big Boy and I remember him doodling on a plate in ketchup making like the most abstract and amazing drawings on his plate while the two of us were just talking and chatting it up and him watching the two of us and I could see in his eyes him starting to see his movie.
我知道他也是你的挚友。他真的是史上最伟大的导演之一。你们两个在所有这些伟大的电影中都有过非常棒的合作。第一部是《蓝丝绒》，我们刚才聊到过。能不能稍微讲讲那是怎么促成的，你是在试镜时遇到他的，嗯？当时他在为哪个角色试镜？17岁，老实说他非常优秀……但疯狂的是，我和选角导演以及大卫一起谈了大约45分钟，无所不谈，而我根本没有为他试镜。选角导演在几部电影里见过我，所以大概向他推荐了我，
It was amazing feeling as an actor. It wasn't about us necessarily or us separately, but as a whole there was something that he felt was right for the film. So that was really cool experience. That is great. Amazingly, I got cast. Did you, when you started making Blue Velvet, well, it sounds like you did at that moment,
但我认为他当时还没看过我的表演。他只是凭直觉。他非常坚信要遵循直觉。而且谈得很顺利。我是说，我当时已经（你知道的）太喜欢他的电影了。所以这对我有极其重大的意义。我看过《eraserhead》（《橡皮头》）。我看过《象人》，所以我被他彻底迷住了。然后他邀请我和凯尔·麦克拉克伦去鲍勃大男孩餐厅吃午餐，我记得他在盘子用番茄酱涂鸦，画出盘子上最抽象、最惊艳的画，当时我们两个就在那儿聊天，而他一边看着我们俩，我能从他的眼里看出他开始构思他的电影了。
understand that you were doing something different, like that doing with him was different. I didn't know what it was going to be, or it was such an insane, brilliant and insane script and world. Terrifying and beautiful and all the things that, you know, and hilarious and all the things that Blue Velvet is. But I had just started college. I was on day two when I got offered the movie and was beside myself and was told that I couldn't leave school. they wouldn't let me have a leave of absence so I went to the head of the program I was in
作为演员，那是一种奇妙的感觉。这不一定关乎我们个人，也不是关于我们各自的表现，而是作为一个整体，他觉得有些东西很适合这部电影。所以那真的是一次非常酷的经历。太棒了。神奇的是，我被选上了。当你开始拍摄《蓝丝绒》时，听起来你当时就意识到你在做一些不同的事情，就像和他合作是与众不同的。我不知道它最终会变成什么样，或者说这是一个多么疯狂、才华横溢又疯狂的剧本和世界。它既可怕又美丽，兼具了（你知道的）蓝丝绒所拥有的一切特质，既搞笑又包含万千。但我刚上大学。我开学第二天就接到了这部电影的邀约，当时我欣喜若狂，却被告知我不能离开学校。
to say here's the script here's everything can I have a tutor and I'll you know make a you know behind the scenes like I'll do whatever I can do please please and I remember saying to this professor I just have this feeling
他们不准许我请假，所以我去找了我所在的项目的负责人，
this is my college education and they told me that not only would I never be invited back to this university if I chose the movie, but that I was making, you know, the most radical mistake of my life. And so I remember entering that whole experience thinking, which I don't think I ever would have understood if I hadn't watched my parents with these directors and had this feeling with David, like this is my, not only home, but this is my teacher this is my college this will be right i mean in some unconscious way i think i did know
对他说：“剧本在这儿，什么都在这儿，我能请个家教吗？我会（你知道的）在幕后赶进度，我会尽我所能去做，求求你们了，求求你们。”我记得当时对这位教授说，我就是有这种感觉——
this is the greatest opportunity you're literally at a crossroads you were literally at a crossroads and you chose to go that way and it seems it seems that you made the right choice we don't have to name that professor by name but if you'd like to take the opportunity i would shame them that'd be fine right please well if you if you if you what was what was running second place uh as far as a possible career path for you. Was there ever anything else on your radar? Or since then, like if somebody said you can't do this anymore,
这是我的大学教育。他们告诉我，如果我选择了这部电影，不仅永远不会被这所大学再次邀请，而且我正在犯下（你知道的）我一生中最激进的错误。所以我记得怀着这种想法进入了那段经历，我想，如果我没有看过我父母与这些导演合作，没有对大卫产生这种感觉，我是永远不会理解这一点的：这不仅是我的家，也是我的老师，这是我的大学，这会是正确的。我是说，在某种潜意识里，我想我确实知道——
got to do something else to I'd be pretty fucked. Really? Yeah, I think I'm good. Now I would definitely be. At like 12, I had at 12, I had an idea about being a child psychologist. That was really interesting to me.
这是最棒的机会，你真的站在了十字路口。你真的站在了十字路口，而你选择了那条路，看来你做出了正确的选择。我们不必点那位教授的名字，但如果你想借此机会谴责他一下，那也行，对吧？求之不得。好吧，如果你——如果——在你可能的职业生涯规划中，排在第二位的是什么？你的雷达里曾经出现过其他选择吗？或者从那以后，如果有人说你不能再做这个了，
As Will knows, I loved being a swimmer. Yeah. Wait, wait, Laura, a psychologist for children, not a 12-year-old psychologist. Not a child psychiatrist. Right. Yes.
必须得做点别的，那我可就惨了。真的吗？是的，我觉得我很擅长这个。大概在12岁的时候，我有过当一名儿童心理学家的想法。那对我来说真的很有趣。
We'll be right back. And back to the show. Where does the swimming come from? Yeah, she's a swimmer. When did that start? Love it since I was little and then became, you know, just in school, competitive swimmer. and Will knows
正如威尔所知，我喜欢游泳。对。等等，等等，劳拉，是儿童心理学家，而不是12岁的心理学家。不是儿童精神病学家。对的，没错。
way too much about it. And in the movie, is this thing on, you play an Olympic volleyball player. And I remember when we were starting, and you're like, God, I really got to like figure this out. I got to find how, like, I got to do the work. And you went and you played volleyball right or something
我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。游泳是怎么回事？对，她是个游泳健将。这从什么时候开始的？我从小就喜欢，然后（你知道的）在学校里成了竞技游泳运动员，
or you took lessons or something like that. Really? And in the movie, in the shots and everything, I'm like, oh my God, I completely believe that you were a volleyball player for the Olympics. I mean, 100%. Yeah, it's true. Thank you.
而且威尔对这方面了解得太多了。在这部电影《is this thing on》中，你饰演了一名奥运排球运动员。我还记得我们刚开始的时候，你说：“天哪，我真的得把这个搞清楚。我得弄明白——我得做功课。”然后你就去打排球了，对吧？还是上了课什么的？真的吗？
Wait, I don't remember you. I've seen it twice. I don't remember. Was it just the one picture that has you? There's a picture and there's one quick cutaway of me. Yeah. Got it. Okay.
在这部电影里，在镜头和所有画面中，我都觉得：“哦，天哪，我完全相信你曾是一名奥运会排球运动员。”我是说，百分之百。是的，是真的。谢谢你。
Spiking. But I think it's mostly, well, two things. One, as well and I both can talk about. You guys all know that Bradley is like such a radical, disciplined beyond compare perfectionist in his like a drive of whatever it is. The truth, the Philly Cheese Stakes sandwich, the movie, you know, it's got to be the one. And so, you know, I feel like I pride myself sometimes on throwing myself into things. But in this case, I was like, oh yeah, even if it's not in the movie, I got to get.
等等，我不记得你了。我看过两遍。我不记得了。难道只有那个有你的镜头吗？有一个镜头，还有一个我的一闪而过的快切镜头。对。明白了。好的。
get up two hours before and train. Because, you know, the manner at which you hold yourself and the way you carry your body when it's embedded in you is, yeah, is different. And her manner is different. And Sean, Jason, Sean, maybe you know a little bit, but when we were talking about, like when Bradley said, I think that Laura's going to do, agreed to do this,
扣球。但我觉得主要还是——好吧，两件事。第一，正如威尔和我都能谈到的。你们都知道布拉德利是一个非常激进、纪律严明到无以复加的完美主义者，无论是对什么的追求。真相、费城牛排三明治、电影（你知道的），都必须做到最好。所以，（你知道的）我觉得我有时为自己能全身心投入而感到自豪。但在这部电影里，我觉得：“哦，是的，哪怕这些镜头不会出现在电影里，我也得提前两个小时起床进行训练。”
which totally elevated everything that we were talking about doing once she agreed. And he always describes it. He's like, this character needs to be an assassin. And Laura is a fucking assassin. And so when she started to really inhabit that idea of stuff. I know. No, because she's literally killed people.
因为（你知道的）你保持身姿的仪态，以及当你将角色内化后展现身体的方式，确实是不一样的。她的仪态与众不同。肖恩，杰森，肖恩，也许你们知道一点，但当我们谈到——就像布拉德利说：“我觉得劳拉会愿意接演这个角色。”
She's killed people. She's a sniper. We wouldn't get into that. She does. She has silencers. She does piano wire. She's an assassin. No, but she, that she, you know, this idea.
一旦她点头答应，就把我们正在讨论的所有事情都提升到了一个全新的高度。他总是这样形容她。他说：“这个角色必须是一个刺客。而劳拉就是一个他妈的刺客。”所以当她开始真正揣摩那个概念时……我知道。不，因为她真的杀过人。
And then she started to carry herself with that. thing like she had this sort of like that sort of competitive athlete edge tour it was fucking rad and we did some work beforehand so will so what was that like when you started to go through just even just the reading the script sort of rehearsal process i'm assuming you guys did was there a moment where you're sitting across the table from laura and you start seeing laura do laura stuff and like you start seeing that talent you're like oh fuck i better really kind of yeah 100% I mean we we have the luxury
她杀过人。她是个狙击手。我们就不细聊这个了。她会的。她有消音器。她用钢琴线。她是个刺客。不，但是她——她（你知道的）有这种想法。
I mean J.B. I will tell you yes first of all a lot and she's the most gracious and warmest and kindest person and really I can vouch for that held yeah held my hand and we were such partners and she was just and we started and we read a bunch
然后她开始带着那种气场行事，就像她身上带有一种竞争型运动员的犀利边缘，这实在太酷了。我们在开拍前做了一些准备工作，所以，威尔，当你开始仅仅是读剧本、经历排练流程时，那是什么感觉？我猜你们做过排练。有没有那么一刻，你坐在劳拉对面，开始看到劳拉施展劳拉的绝活，看到那种才华时，你心想：“哦，操，我最好真的得……”对，百分之百。我是说，我们有这个荣幸——
you know early on and went through the script and she had so many great ideas for leading up to it and then we went through this great rehearsal process together and did this workshop which was super and where we got to know each other and that's why we know way too much about each other's lives.
我是说，JB，我告诉你，是的，首先，她非常大度、热情、善良，真的，我可以担保。她（你知道的）拉着我的手，我们是如此默契的伙伴，她只是……我们开始时一起读了很多剧本，
And then we ended up, you know, yeah, when you're just in this, you know, in the scene, of course it occurred to me that I'm like, oh, wait. And I said this to Laura, like early on. I said, like, you know, for me, this is such a leap. Again, Laura, you can plug your ears or whatever, and I'm embarrassed her. You know, she's Laura Dern Academy Award-winning, you know,
（你知道的）很早就开始通读剧本，她对剧情的发展有那么多绝妙的想法，然后我们一起经历了非常棒的排练流程，做了一次超级棒的工作坊，我们在那里互相了解，这就是为什么我们对彼此的生活了解得有点太多了。
just super talent. and watching her, it's like playing tennis with a great. And it just does nothing but just, you know, it raises all boats, you know, high time. But I was nervous, and I expressed it. I told her that. And I said, you know, I feel nervous
然后我们结束了……是的，当你身处（你知道的）那个场景中时，我当然会产生这种想法，心想：“哦，等等。”我早期就对劳拉说过这个。我说：“（你知道的）对我来说，这真的是一次巨大的飞跃。再次提醒，劳拉，你可以捂住耳朵什么的，我要让她难堪了。”你知道的，她是劳拉·邓恩，奥斯卡奖得主，（你知道的）
and she was really gentle with me. You know, it was awesome. Well, let me just say this is a great privilege on SmartList because being a radical fan of all three of you, not to mention your incredible friendship and the way you can destroy or mock each other with so much love is an art no one else and no other friendship knows.
超级天才。看着她，就像是和高手打网球。这除了（你知道的）水涨船高之外，没有别的作用，（你知道的）让所有人的水平都随之提高。但我当时很紧张，我也把这表达出来了。我告诉了她。我说：“（你知道的）我感到很紧张。”
But let me be the person who gets to be on Smartless to pay homage to Will's bravery because Sean was there with us. Yeah. And I know, Jason, you've seen it. Like, it is incredible performance. It is incredible. Yeah.
而她对我都非常温柔。（你知道的）这太棒了。好吧，让我这么说，作为SmartLess的铁杆粉丝，能够采访你们三位真的是无上的特权，更不用说你们之间不可思议的友谊，以及你们那种能够带着满满的爱去毁灭或嘲讽彼此的方式，是一种无人能及、其他友谊都无法企及的艺术。
Who he is, what he's willing to reveal, his vulnerability, his willingness to, yes, take my hand and for us to explore everything with each other for these characters and this, you know, 25-year relationship. But, oh, my God, the truth, the heartbreak that he exposes within himself, and to me, is like unparalleled. So it's me who has to say how blessed I was, really like no bullshit to be staring in his eyes and be forced to be honest and see myself in ways sometimes was not comfortable and also beautiful and revelatory.
但请让我成为SmartLess节目中向威尔的勇敢致敬的那个人，因为肖恩当时和我们在一起。是的。而且我知道，杰森，你也看过了。那真的是不可思议的表演。简直难以置信。是的。
What a fucking actor people are. Well, even just the bravery, how it just started even early by Will just like just writing it, you know, with Chappie, like saying, well, yeah, I'm going to try to write a script. And it's not going to be like, you know, silly shit. This is going to be like real stuff from the heart, like a drama, a raw drama. And then like expect it to be taken seriously and read by people that are like Academy Award winning and nominated people.
他是谁，他愿意展露什么，他的脆弱，他愿意——是的——拉起我的手，让我们为了这些角色以及这段（你知道的）25年的关系去共同探索一切。但是，天哪，他在自己内心深处展露出的真实与心碎，对我说来是无与伦比的。所以是我必须要说，我是多么幸运，真的，毫不废话地看着他的双眼，被迫去保持诚实，并在有时并不舒服但又美丽且具有启示性的方式中看到了自己。
And then and then they say, okay, we're doing it. Yeah. Yeah. And it's like, oh, just kidding. Just kidding. Yeah. And now I've got to, like, be a great actor in this thing. And then pulling that off, too.
这演技真是绝了。好吧，仅仅是那种勇敢，从威尔一开始动笔写剧本的时候就开始了，（你知道的）和查比一起，就像是说：“好吧，是的，我要试着写个剧本。而且这不会是那种（你知道的）无聊的烂片，这会是发自内心的真实内容，像是一部戏剧，一部生猛的戏剧。”然后还指望被认真对待，并被像奥斯卡奖得主和提名者那样的人阅读。
Like, it's just pretty fucking cool. So beautiful. Oh, thank you, thank you. It was scary. There were a couple of great moments. And Laura, well, I tell you, this is, we were, we were making the movie, and we were trying to get this scene. We had a crazy, trying to get this, trying to get the scene.
然后——然后他们说：“好吧，我们拍。”对，对。结果就像是：“哦，开玩笑的。开玩笑的。是的。”现在我不得不（你知道的）在这部作品里当个伟大的演员。然后居然还成功把这事儿给成了，
We had a crazy day where we rehearsed all morning with the crew's Just the scene towards the end of the movie. Yeah, and then we shot all afternoon. And it was tough, and we just, you know, it's one of those days where you're just swimming, you're like, did we get it? Are we getting it? Are we close?
这简直太酷了。太美妙了。哦，谢谢，谢谢。当时确实挺吓人的。有几个非常精彩的时刻。劳拉，对了，我告诉你，这是我们在拍电影的时候，我们正努力拍好这场戏。我们经历了疯狂的一天，一整个上午都在和剧组一起排练……仅仅是电影快结束时的一场戏。是的，然后我们整个下午都在拍。过程很艰难，我们只是（你知道的）——那是那种让你觉得像在水里扑腾的日子，你会想：“我们拍到了吗？我们拍到了吗？我们拍得够好吗？”
Or are we super far away, and are we just swimming even further away from what we won and all this kind of stuff? And over the week, and it was a Friday. And so we rapped late on the Friday night, and over the weekend, Laura and Bradley and I ended up having a bunch of conversations over the weekend.
“还是说我们差得十万八千里？我们是不是在离我们想要的效果越来越远？”诸如此类。整个周末——那是星期五。所以我们在周五深夜收工，而在周末的时候，劳拉、布拉德利和我最终在周末进行了好几次对话。
And Laura and I had this, I don't know how you felt, but for me, that was such a turning point. And we had this really awesome, honest conversation about just all of it and being honest with each other about how we felt and it was like this crazy turning point for us in the movie.
我和劳拉有过这样的经历——我不知道你当时是什么感觉，但对我来说，那是一个巨大的转折点。我们进行了一次非常棒、非常坦诚的对话，关于这一切，向彼此坦诚我们当时的真实感受，对我们在这部电影里的拍摄来说，这就像是一个疯狂的转折点。
And from that point on, we were such partners. Yes. And I take, I love that people respond to our relationship in the movie, but I will say that, like, you were, that, it was born out of really, real experience. Yes, a million percent. Yeah, you can tell the chemistry is real.
从那一刻起，我们就成了真正的伙伴。是的。我喜欢人们对我们在电影中关系的反应，但我得说，（你知道的）那种关系是诞生于真正、真实的体验之中的。是的，百分之百。是的，你能看出那种化学反应是真实的。
Yeah, I love it. Yeah, and it's interesting that we didn't get there because the first sort of half of the shoot, we were in this antagonistic dynamic. Yeah. And so it was like when we had to truly face each other and be boundaryless about who we were than, you know, and you really held my heart in it. And, you know, I said stuff, you don't, you know, that's what's incredible, right?
是的，我喜欢这样。是的，有趣的是，我们一开始并非如此，因为拍摄的前半段，我们处于一种对立的动态关系中。是的。所以，当我们需要真正面对彼此，并且在彼此是谁这件事上毫无保留时，（你知道的）你真的在其中给了我心灵的抚慰。而且，（你知道的）我说了一些……你不会（你知道的）——这就是不可思议的地方，对吧？
In these intimate relationships, as you were talking about Jason, like, there we are in this familial story that we're trying to tell all together, but that we were truly the most honest I've ever been with someone. Me too, ever. And I remember we showed up, we shot this scene that's not in the movie where we go to the hospital.
正如你刚才所说，杰森，在这些亲密的关系中，我们置身于我们试图共同讲述的这个家庭故事里，但我们却做到了我与任何人在一起时所经历过的最极致的坦诚。我也是，从来没有过。我记得我们到片场时，拍了那场电影里没有的去医院的戏。
It was the first thing on Monday. And we all, and we, so we had this great conversation, a couple conversations, and we showed up. And it was like, from that moment on, it was just unreal. Like that scene, it just didn't work in the movie. The scene is fucking great. Yeah, yeah. And it was like, oh, it just changed everything.
那是周一的第一场戏。我们所有人都——我们进行了那次绝佳的对话，好几次对话，然后我们出现在片场。从那一刻起，一切都变得不可思议。就像那场戏，它只是没能放进电影里。那场戏本身他妈的太棒了。对，对。这就好像，哦，它改变了一切。
It was really wild. And for me, anyway, it was the first time I've experienced me. Can we enjoy that scene on DVD extras? Yeah, I'm going to load it up on the internet pretty soon. Okay, great. Of you miss DVD extras. I do miss DVD extras. And Sean and Scotty.
这真的很疯狂。对我和其他人来说，这是我第一次体验到……我们能在DVD花絮里欣赏到那场戏吗？对，我很快就会把它上传到网上。太好了。如果你怀念DVD花絮的话。我是怀念DVD花絮的。肖恩和斯科蒂。
I mean, what miraculous best friends. I mean, Will actually has them in his life. I just pretended, and you were the best friends I'd ever had. We ended up on a group text. I felt so excited and proud. Yeah, yeah. I love that. The first day we showed up, Willie was so sweet.
我的天，多么奇妙的挚友啊。我是说，威尔的生活中真的有这样的人。我只是假装，而你们就是我拥有的最好的朋友。我们建了一个群聊。我感到既兴奋又骄傲。对，对。我喜欢这样。第一天我们到片场时，威利太贴心了。
He said, I feel like my family just showed up on set. It was very kind. It's true. Yeah, it was so fun. Sean had to do. Sean does this scene, by the way. I don't know if you've told this. Sean does this scene.
他说：“我觉得我的家人刚刚来到片场。”这真的太暖心了。确实如此。是的，太有趣了。肖恩得拍……顺便说一句，肖恩有这么一场戏。我不知道你有没有讲过这个。肖恩有这场戏——
Laura knows it, I mean, so we're in the Oyster Bay house and he's got to, he and Scotty have to go and it's a stretch, they had to go in and raid the fridge at night for all the, like, terrible suit and ice cream, right? All right, and you're on the couch, trying to sleep. And so they're supposed to be, and Padley's like, and he goes like, yeah, I think they're kind of high and whatever. Yeah.
劳拉也知道，我是说，我们在牡蛎湾的房子里，他和斯科蒂必须去——这挺勉强的——他们必须在半夜去洗劫冰箱里所有的（你知道的）那些糟糕的甜食和冰淇淋，对吧？对的，而你正躺在沙发上，试图睡觉。所以他们本应该……布拉德利就说，他当时说：“对啊，我觉得他们大概有点嗑大了什么的。”对。
Sean eats a gummy, and so all day he's trying to time when he's going to eat the gummy on that scene. Wow, really, Shawnee? Yeah, thank you. So he kept going to me Like do you think it's too early if I eat it right now? Because I want to eat it right when we shoot it, right? Laura, I want to know like who other than the three of us
肖恩吃了一颗软糖，所以他一整天都在计算自己应该在哪个时间点把这颗软糖吃下去来配合这场戏。哇，真的吗，肖尼？对，谢谢你。所以他一直跑来问我：“你觉得如果我现在吃是不是太早了？因为我想在开拍的那一刻吃掉它，对吧？”劳拉，我想知道，除了我们三个之外，还有谁……
Because I know that's what you would joke around and say But truly, because you've been around it since you were a kid Who were you starstruck the most by growing up Or recently or anything or do you even get it? And I always asked Jason that too Because you guys obviously grew up in the business And I didn't And so I'm always like, wow, I'm still like, wow, wow,
因为我知道这是你会拿来开玩笑说的，但说真的，因为你从小就在这个圈子里长大，在你成长过程中，最让你感到大受震撼的是谁？或者是最近遇到的？或者你甚至会有这种感觉吗？我总是问杰森这个问题，因为你们显然是在这个行业里长大的，而我不是，所以我总是觉得：“哇，我还是会觉得‘哇，哇，’”
Wow. And I know you guys are too, but like, who is, is there a person recently or even when you were younger there, you were like, okay, I can't believe I'm working with this person or I'm meeting this person. I don't know about you, Jason. I feel like, sometimes I feel like I'm the most starstruck. And maybe because the equity for mastering something or loving something was all about movies in my family. So if I meet heroes, I lose my mind. It's movie actors and directors and musicians big time, too. Oh, musicians, yeah. Meeting music heroes is a big deal. Yeah, yeah, for sure. Yeah, yeah, what is that about musicians and athletes and actors? They all kind of want to be one another.
“哇。”我知道你们也是这样，但是……是谁？最近有没有某个人，甚至是你年轻的时候，让你觉得：“天哪，我不敢相信我能和这个人合作”或者“我不敢相信我能见到这个人”？我不知道你怎么样，杰森。我觉得有时我真的是最容易大受震撼的那个人。也许是因为在我家里，对于掌握某项技能或热爱某事的回报全都是关于电影的。所以如果我见到偶像，我就会失去理智。电影演员、导演，还有音乐人也是大牌。哦，音乐人，是的。见到音乐偶像是一件大事。是的，对，绝对是。是的，对，音乐人、运动员和演员到底是怎么回事？他们其实都挺想成为彼此的。
Yeah, yeah, because it's a world you're not in. So it's like, wow, yeah, I get that. It's a crazy thing. But I think for me, like meeting heroes of another time was always such a huge gift. Like Alexander the Great? Alexander the Great was huge. Oh, well, I told you that story.
是的，是的，因为那是一个你并不身处的世界。所以你会觉得：“哇，对，我懂。”这真是一件疯狂的事。但我觉得对我来说，见到另一个时代的偶像一直是一件巨大的礼物。就像亚历山大大帝？亚历山大大帝太厉害了。哦，对了，我跟你讲过那个故事。
Like I said, he knows all my stories. You had said. No, because I remember when Rashida Jones was on, I was like, she just grew up with like Michael Jackson coming over for dinner. I'm like, that's crazy. I know. I know. I've become friends.
就像我说的，他知道我所有的故事。你之前说过。不，因为我记得拉什达·琼斯上节目时，我说过她从小就是迈克尔·杰克逊来家里吃晚饭的。我说这太疯狂了。我知道。我知道。我已经和卡洛尔·伯内特成了朋友。
Can I say that? Which is insane and so privileged with Carol Burnett because I produced this show, Comreale. and, like, working with her, knowing her. And even though she knew my mom and, you know, there are these crossover things, but when you have your own relationship with these legends that raised you on their talent,
我能这么说吗？这简直疯狂又享有特权，因为我制作了这档节目《Comreale》，能与她合作、了解她。尽管她认识我妈妈，（你知道的）这其中有一些跨界的渊源，但当你与这些传奇人物建立起属于你自己的关系时——是他们的才华抚养你长大，
raised you on their shows, that's crazy. Actually, I did just find, and Jason will relate to this because it was of an era that we grew up around, my mom's battle of the network Star's Award. No. No way.
是他们的节目伴随你成长——这真的很疯狂。其实，我刚刚确实发现了一件东西，杰森会有所共鸣，因为那是我们一同成长的一个时代的东西——我妈妈的“网络明星对抗赛”奖杯。不会吧。绝不可能。
CBS won when she was on the team. Yes. No way. And it was such a, I became such a fan. I was like, oh my God, Battle of the Network Stars. This is like the greatest award. I can't believe I have her Battle of the Network Stars award. Because you realize it's the way things entered your living room.
当她在那个队伍里时，哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）赢了。没错。不可能吧。我当时成了狂热粉丝。我当时想：“哦，天哪，网络明星对抗赛。这简直是最大的奖项。”我简直不敢相信我拥有她的网络明星对抗赛奖杯。因为你会意识到，这就是事物进入你客厅的方式。
Like Lucy, there will never be a greater hero. Right. It was the greatest show, right? I mean, why don't they bring that goddamn show back? I know. Did you imagine? Didn't we talk? And we talked, we actually, we were at a dinner with Ted Sarando's telling him they should make Battle of the Network stars.
就像露西一样，永远不会有比她更伟大的偶像了。对啊，那曾是最棒的节目，对吧？我是说，他们为什么不把那个该死的节目带回来？我懂。你能想象吗？我们没聊过吗？我们其实聊过，我们当时和特德·萨兰多斯一起吃晚饭，告诉他他们应该重拍《网络明星对抗赛》。
Right. Battle of the platform stars, right? Yeah, the streaming stars. Yeah. Streaming stars. Exactly. Netflix people against Amazon people, against Apple people against HBO people. Killer.
对。《平台明星对抗赛》，对吧？对，流媒体明星。对。流媒体明星。没错。Netflix的人对阵亚马逊的人，对阵苹果的人，对阵HBO的人。绝了。
How great would that be? Netflix has Squid Game, guys. But then what would you put it on? Yeah. We know who's winning. To be. Tooby, I put it on Toopy. Jason, do you?
那会有多棒？Netflix有《鱿鱼游戏》呢，伙计们。但到时候你要把它放在哪个平台播？对啊。我们都知道谁会赢。Tubi，我要把它放在Tubi上播。杰森，你觉得呢？
I'm not sure, do I have Toobie? That's such an old reference. That's an old smartless reference, which is a weird thing to say. An old raid. Oh, man. Laura, Laura, I could just, I could just touch it all day. Save it for the sequel, you guys. Yeah.
我不确定，我有Tubi吗？这真的是个老梗了。这是一个老派的SmartLess老梗，说出来还挺奇怪的。老梗。哦，天哪。劳拉，劳拉，我简直——我简直恨不得一整天都黏着它。留着续集再用吧，伙计们。对。
Oh, we've already discovered this thing still on. We've discussed this thing still on. And then you came up with the title for the third or fourth film. Do you remember? What was it? Like somebody turned this thing the fuck off or something? Oh yeah, so somebody, please turn this thing off.
哦，我们已经讨论过这东西还在录了。我们讨论过这东西还在录。然后你为第三部或第四部电影想出了片名。你还记得吗？是什么来着？就像是“有人把这该死的东西关掉”之类的？哦，对了，所以有人——请把这东西关掉。
Please turn this thing off. That's hilarious. The final adventure. Say the date when the movie comes out again, so we know. December 19th. December 19th. December 19th. December 19th is this thing on starring the great Laura Dernard.
请把这东西关掉。太搞笑了。最终的冒险。再报一遍电影上映的日期，好让我们记住。12月19日。12月19日。12月19日。12月19日，《is this thing on》上映，由伟大的劳拉·邓恩主演。
Will Arnette. and the Green Lord and Sean Hayes and Scott Ice Noggle and her day Bradley Cooper in a Bradley Cooper film this Christmas take your heart on a can I do the old my own trailer please do take your heart
威尔·阿奈特。还有伟大的劳拉、肖恩·海耶斯、斯科特·伊因格尔，以及她的老搭档布拉德利·库珀，一部布拉德利·库珀电影。今年圣诞节，带上你的心去……我能模仿一下我自己的预告片腔调吗？请务必来一个。带上你的心去……
take your heart on a funny bone dried a funny bone what? Every once in a while a film comes along that'll touch your heart and then I feel good dude That's literally every trailer.
带上你的心去感受笑点……感受什么？每隔一段时间，总会有一部电影出现，它会触动你的心弦，然后我觉得感觉不错，老兄。这简直就是每一部预告片的套路。
I know. Like in the 80s, every trailer did that, you know. Laura, we love you. Thank you. Laura, we love you. I love you. I'm so honored to be on this brilliant,
我知道。就像在80年代，每一部预告片都这么干，你知道的。劳拉，我们爱你。谢谢你们。劳拉，我们爱你。我爱你们。能参与到这个被称为SmartLess的辉煌、
incredible ride that is called Smartless and your guys' friendship makes me so happy. It's overdue. I know. I guess we had to time it to your release and everything. I know. It was long overdue. We had to wait.
不可思议的旅程中，我感到万分荣幸，你们这群人的友谊让我感到无比快乐。这早就该有了。我知道。我猜我们得把时间安排得正好配合你的上映之类的事。我知道。这真的迟来太久了。我们等了好久。
We've been talking about this since March. But, Laura, I will see you really soon. I love you. I love all of you. And I'm going to see you, literally, I'm seeing you instantly. I think we're like taking it on the road. As soon as you're done on your adventure right now. We're going to, I'll see you in London.
我们从三月就开始谈论这个了。但是，劳拉，我很快就会见到你。我爱你们。我爱你们所有人。而且我马上——字面意义上的马上就要见到你了。我想我们大概要开始巡回宣传了。等你结束眼下的冒险之后。我们要去——我会在伦敦见到你。
I'll see you in London. And I'll see you guys very soon, I hope. Yeah, it's some sort of a holiday party or something. I'm sad we aren't making Ozark anymore, but I know what's other things. Yeah, well. In your future, please go. You know what I got last night when we were waiting, we're at the valet, real Hollywood moment.
我会在伦敦见到你。希望我能很快见到你们各位。对，大概是什么假日派对之类的。我很遗憾我们不再拍《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）了，但我知道未来还有别的事。是的，好吧。祝你未来一切顺利。你知道我昨晚等车的时候遇到了什么吗？我们在代客泊车处，标准的荷里活时刻。
Yeah. And Ed Shearan came over to Jason Bateman. Jason was complaining because the guy lost his ticket for his ride. It was great. I almost threw my wig at him. Don't make me snap this off. And I was making it work because he's legit frustrated. I'm like, look at Bateman.
对。埃德·希兰（Ed Sheeran）朝杰森·贝特曼走了过来。杰森当时正在抱怨，因为代客泊车的人把他的车票弄丢了。那场面太棒了。我当时差点把假发朝他扔过去。别逼我把这个扯下来。我当时还在强颜欢笑，因为他是真的挺沮丧的。我想：“看看贝特曼。”
He'd gumming up the line and stuff. He was not happy. And then Ed Shearan came over and said, oh man, I love Ozark. And they gave him a hug. And they hung. Oh, that's right. Did you know that was Ed Shearer?
他把队伍都给堵塞了之类的。他当时很不高兴。然后埃德·希兰走了过来，说：“哦，天哪，我太喜欢《黑钱胜地》了。”然后他们拥抱了一下。他们在一块儿聊了聊。哦，原来是这样。你知道那是埃德·希兰吗？
You don't know anything. I did. I figured it out. No, of course. And then you handed him your wig as a thank you. And I said, yeah, let me give you that. Let me sign this for you. It's right there on the netting. A Sharpie will work on the netting.
你什么都不知道。我知道。我认出来了。不，当然。然后你把假发递给他当做谢意。我说：“对，把这个给你吧。我为你签个名吧。”就签在网状内衬上。记号笔写在网衬上完全没问题。
Sure. And the label. Uh-huh. Oh, God. He's a label maker as well for his wigs. I love you guys. Love you, Lord, Dern. I love you guys so much.
当然。还有标签。呃-huh。哦，天哪。他还是他自己那些假发的标签制造者。我爱你们。爱你们，劳拉·邓恩。我太爱你们了。
We'll see you. And I'll send to the fire. So soon. We'll see you very soon, Laura. We love you. Love you. Thanks, guys, for having me. Bye.
回头见。我要去向烈火发送……太快了。我们很快就会见到你，劳拉。我们爱你。爱你们。谢谢你们邀请我，各位。拜拜。
Bye. Bye, bye, bye, guys. That Laura Dern, how lucky did you and Bradley get by getting her? I mean, it's just like so dependent on somebody that kind of comes out of the screen. It's like someone you just, you want to make an emotional investment in, right? You just, you can't help but love her. And also the pedigree. The pedigree, and she's just.
拜拜。拜拜，拜拜，拜拜，各位。那个劳拉·邓恩，你和布拉德利请到她，究竟有多幸运？我是说，这简直太依赖于那种仿佛能直接从银幕里走出来的人了。就像那种你会——想要对她进行情感投资的人，对吧？你就是忍不住会爱上她。而且还有她的演艺世家背景。演艺世家背景，而且她本人就是……
And the talent and the history. She's got no choice in the talent She's one of those people It's just in her I mean before I knew her For years and years and years and years We would go, how you durn Because of her
还有她的才华和过往经历。她在表演上根本没有别的选择，她就是那种人。这天赋是天生的。我是说，在我认识她之前，
Really? Yeah Oh you'd say that to your friends Remember those times? Yeah, remember that? How you durn? Yeah. No?
好多年、好多年、好多年里，我们都会学着说“How you durn”（你怎么邓恩），模仿她的姓氏。真的吗？是的。哦，你会对你的朋友们这么说吗？还记得那些时光吗？是的，还记得吗？How you durn？是的。没有吗？
I'm gonna take that. We weren't in Glenell in Illinois, man So. Yeah. I've been nose hair. What humor in that region? Are you smelling your fingers? What?
我要接这个梗。我们当时又不在伊利诺伊州的格伦埃尔，老兄。所以。是的。我鼻毛都出来了。那片地区的幽默感可真行。你在闻自己的手指吗？什么？
Do you just pull out of a fucking nose hair? Hey, why don't you just By the way, every time I see you, You've got like these fucking antlers coming out of your nose. What is going on the fucking... The MSG has gotten to you. Are you drunk on MSG from the Chinese food?
你刚才是从鼻子里揪出了一根该死的鼻毛吗？嘿，你为什么不——顺便说一句，每次我看到你，你鼻子里都长着像这种该死的鹿角一样的东西。这到底是怎么回事，他妈的……麦芽糊精（MSG）害了你。你是吃中餐吃MSG吃醉了吗？
What's happening? No, it's hanging out. I know, but you guys get... You have them, too. Sure, but I attack them with a... We're going to be out of here in a minute. Next time, Scotty comes in to reapply your lip balm. Have them whack a few hairs out of your nose.
怎么回事？不，它就挂在那儿。我知道，但你们这些家伙……你也有。当然，但我会用……我们一会儿就离开这儿。下次斯科特进来帮你重新涂唇膏的时候，顺便让他帮你拔几根鼻毛下来。
Okay, I put it on the list. Okay. Is it coming out of your ears, too? No, I never get it out of my ears. Really? Yeah. She did, though, mention, Laura didn't mention the word later hosen. I was, want to say what, you know, the same thing of later, hosen, right?
好吧，我把它记在单子上了。好的。它也从你的耳朵里长出来了吗？没有，我耳朵里从来不长。真的吗？是的。不过她确实提到了，劳拉提到了“later hosen”（德语lederhosen，皮裤）这个词。我当时就想说，（你知道的）和“later hosen”一样，对吧？
Like, it's kind of the same thing as saying, you know. Later, hosen. Well, I mean. Like, buy me, hosen. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Hey, bye, hosen, that's what I'm saying. Or buy hoser. That's what we say.
就像，这和说（你知道的）差不多。Later hosen。我是说。就像，By me, hosen。对，对，对。嘿，Bye hoser（再见，乡巴佬），这就是我想说的。或者Bye hoser。我们都是这么说的。
Oh, bye, hoser. Oh, giver. Bye he, hoser. Go on the giver. Bye Yep Smartless Smart
哦，Bye hoser。哦，Giver（给力）。Bye he, hoser。继续给力。拜 没错 Smartless
Smartless Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry Rob Armjav
Smartless由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴尔巴戈·豪斯100%有机手工打造。
and Bennett Barbago House. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。